foreign
er's new movie the machine has been
dominating the comedy news cycle this
past week after coming out in theaters
Memorial Day weekend it's been said by
many that the success or failure of this
movie may be the deciding factor when it
comes to the future of comedians either
creating blockbuster hits with massive
Studio budgets or still having to rely
on the outdated Hollywood system and
their industry censorship even with all
of this hanging in the balance there was
still a surprisingly large divide
amongst comedy fans on the internet in
regards to the machine most people
really wanted this movie to do well
either as a fan of Bert or just
comedians in general but they're still
more than a handful of people who for
whatever reason made it known that
they're preying on the downfall of this
movie and rooting outwardly for a flop
whether you came into this video as a
Bert supporter or as one of his doubters
there's still three questions on
everyone's mind surrounding the release
of this movie that are yet to be
answered being number one what happened
to the premiere will there be a machine
two three and four and most importantly
did the movie lose or make money we're
taking a look at the actual numbers we
can answer each one of these questions
in depth starting off with the one thing
every comedian was posting about last
week Bert's wild Premiere this might be
the most handsome young man in comedy
right now and Matt Wright me and Matt
Rife together see that the premiere
honestly looked like everything that
you'd expect from Bert the entire event
was basically just a huge party start to
finish and the list of guests in
attendance ranged everywhere from random
athletes and porn stars to celebrities
like Snoop Dogg plus tons of comedians
in attendance like Jim Jefferies and Tom
Segura who surprised Bert on the red
carpet after initially saying he was not
planning on attending the premiere
doesn't reply hey man are you gonna make
it to the premiere please tell me about
the premiere no reply
and then call him and he's like hey man
I can't [__] make it and I go
actually I'm actually bothered by it
like I'm bothered you're my best friend
we have a podcast together and we have a
movie set up over at legendary fat
astronauts you guys need to make it
that's okay no one no one replies no one
replies Tom hits me up I have a
publicist texting me this morning I have
a signing for my book which is going
into paperback
oh yeah when it does make the move from
hard to paper it is yeah that is a very
big deal and he goes I can't get out of
it I'm coordinating with my publisher
and it's Barnes and Noble so it's kind
of a big deal it's coming out in paper
deck aren't they closing down yeah
I'm the fool in the story yeah because
I'm listening to a Barnes and Noble he's
like plus I have a VHS signing at
Blockbuster and fries and I think I got
a good price products and I think
straight guys can get AIDS and he's like
all the things that we thought back then
and I said I got you no worries and he
goes hey man congrats on your big day
I'm so sorry I couldn't make it very
excited to see you in this movie and in
movie theaters have a great weekend I
love you have fun and I just wrote
thanks Tommy I wish you could be here I
understand I love you and then this
shows up he showed up I know that
because you told me they showed up I did
they're beautiful and I cried he cried
real hard the budget for this movie has
been reported to be anywhere between 20
and 35 million dollars for the machine
according to this movie website that I
found that's literally called the
numbers the machine was released last
weekend in the United States and Canada
and is projected to gross around 5
million dollars from the 2409 theaters
over its four day Memorial Day opening
weekend with a one week average run per
theater and a leg ratio of 1.2 the film
made 2.3 million dollars on its first
day and had a domestic vs International
share of 98.9 domestic meaning the
machine was almost exclusively viewed in
the U.S after taking a closer look at
these initial numbers it's clear that
the machine failed to make back Sony's
entire Budget on opening weekend but in
the movie world that by no means makes
this project a flop just take the new
Nike movie air for example with a loaded
cast featuring Ben Affleck Matt Damon
Chris Tucker and Jason Bateman they had
a 90 million dollar budget and a massive
worldwide appeal and yet still fell
short of making their money back in
theaters but air has already been put on
Hulu so it can hit a whole new
demographic a whole new audience a
massive audience at that which I assume
is what's next for the machine these
huge production companies like Sony are
very aware of how important success is
on the streaming websites and if their
strategy heading into this thing was to
only keep Burke's movie in theaters for
one weekend in the first place it's safe
to assume the plan for the machine was
always to continue making money on one
of the well-known streaming services
after being released in theaters it also
seems like we'll still get to see plenty
of Big Time comedians starring in Big
Time films moving forward Sebastian's
new movie called about my father is out
right now in theaters as well featuring
Robert De Niro as the actor playing his
dad and even on a smaller scale Comics
still producing their own projects is
continuing to become the norm whether it
be their own specials sketch shows
movies or even books like we've seen
recently from Tom Segura Joey Diaz and
now Tim Dylan Tim's new book titled
death by Boomers how the worst
generation destroyed the planet but
first a child is now available for
pre-order online and according to the
book's description death by Boomers
details the parenting style that made
him a nearly perfect person a closeted
gay cocaine addict who enthusiastically
supported the Iraq War and didn't get a
credit score until he was 36. also fat
this book will be enjoyed by anyone
raised by a boomer or anyone genuinely
curious about the generation of people
who endured the greatest hardships known
to man mall traffic and occasional lines
at the grocery store take a trip down
memory lane with Tim and his friends as
they navigate growing up with these
proud self-righteous Boomers you know
them now as a tribe of Facebook Warriors
but once upon a time they ruled this
land some call the suburbs they were
kings and queens of the drive-through
and if you walk down a Street in Long
Island you can still hear them in a
faint voice telling the tale of someone
who's wrong to them this looks awesome
your your title death by Boomers how the
worst generation destroyed the planet
but first a child
it was an amazing title no it's great
and what it is is my father is 70 and my
mother is God only knows where she is
she may not be with us anymore but what
I wanted to do before they died was just
one more disgraceful moment yeah like a
head hung low moment where I could share
all these like horrific stories uh from
growing up with boom when I love Boomers
boomers are funny it's not a woe it's me
book yeah boomers are deeply selfish
narcissistic monsters sent to destroy
the Earth they've destroyed Society but
sem Dylan autobiography slash Memoir of
sorts sounds so electric so funny the
description was hilarious honestly this
is long overdue thank God people like
Joey Diaz and Tim Dylan are finally
writing out their life stories in book
form giving us comedy fans what we've
always wanted I've already pre-ordered a
copy of Tim's new book so we can make a
recap video for everyone right here on
joke World once it arrives guest spots
from last week The Joe Rogan Experience
had protect our Parks number eight two
bears one cave was Tom and Ryan Blaney
kill Tony this week was with Brian
Holtzman and Ian Edwards Mark Norman was
on take your shoes off we might be drunk
at a Mike vacchione Mike was also the
guest on Chrissy chaos Bert Kreischer
was on bad friends Will Compton was a
guest on Matt and Shane's secret podcast
and the Tim Dillon show featured guest
Tom Segura and Christina P it is like an
art form to be of how to get out of
things within this world in the comedy
podcast you're always like no the thing
is dude I um
I'm having ankles yeah
I thought you broke here I'm like no I
did but I found out my ankle's weak too
so I use my mother a lot because she's
in a mental institution yeah that's a
good one so I just go what's great is
like my mother's not doing well now
here's the thing my mother's never been
doing well yeah it's been 30 years of my
mother not doing well I don't even know
what my mother doing well would look
like what would that be yeah she's a
morbidly obese schizophrenic so if my
mother walked to the door of her room
and opened it herself it's a win yeah so
what's this past weekend with Thea Von
had on Brianna chicken fry Joey Diaz was
on flagrant Howie Mandel was a guest on
the Harlan Highway whiskey Ginger talked
with Angela Johnson Reyes Dave Stone was
on the Honeydew Brandon Wardell was on
stavy's world Pete Holmes was on the
blocks podcast and yamanika Saunders was
on you know what dude as far as brand
new stand-up specials are either out
right now or coming out soon or maybe
they've been out for a little bit but we
haven't mentioned it on the comedy news
yet so we're just mentioning it now for
the first time those kind of specials
I'm an Entertainer just came out on
Netflix last week also Angela Johnson
Reyes say I won't he's out right now on
YouTube that is over a million views as
well as Dave Stone pack a lunch you know
what I'm talking about every shitty job
I ever worked around here there's at
least one dude who had his own dumb
personal mantra
wouldn't shut the hell up about it you
know well they come up here trying that
[__] with me they better pack a lunch
[Laughter]
boss man thinks I'm working on Saturday
he better pack a lunch
let me know in the comments if there's
any new comedy specials that you've
enjoyed recently also a cool joke World
fun fact this is episode 53 of the joke
World comedy news update somehow we've
been doing these for over a year already
so that's that's awesome thank you for
uh watching all these if you have
watching this video watching the other
52 videos if you haven't watched all of
them then thank you for watching this
one I guess all right that's it
and the world is wrld
[Music]